the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hey guys so quick announcement we're not
doing nuclear activation analysis today
because the valve that shoots the
rabbits into the reactor broke and needs
to be repaired so we'll likely just do
this next Friday and instead we'll have
the whole recitation for exam review
like I think we originally originally
planned I also want to say thanks to
whoever said please write lecture notes
for this class it's something I think
needs to be done and I just now biked
back from meeting with the publisher or
a potential publisher to actually get
this done
because I think as you guys have seen
there's no one reading that does this
course justice there are some that are
too easy there are some that are too
hard and there are giant pieces missing
like most of what we're gonna go into
today on source is a background
radiation and where do cosmic rays come
from and what are they so thanks to
whoever said that cuz it spurred me off
on let's make this into a book kind of
thing want to quickly review what we did
last time we went over all the different
units of dose and radiation exposure
from the roentgen which is pretty much
just valid for those measurements in air
and I realized that yesterday I brought
in the civil defense dosimeter and
passed it to one person and we didn't
continue bringing it so I'll bring it to
recitation
it's not in my bag there's the unit of
the gray which is just joules per
kilogram which you can calculate from
stopping power or exponential
attenuation equations this is where you
start because it's how you get from the
world of physics to the world of biology
into units of increased risk or sieverts
which is just gray times a bunch of
quality factors which are either
tabulated or I'd like to see somewhat
been are calculated they are calculated
sometimes but by empirical relations
because it's usually good enough bio
measurements tend to be pretty sloppy
and I'm not that upset that these are
empirical relations and I'm gonna skip
way ahead past the detector stuff we
didn't quite finish up the I f2d idea I
think this is where we ended last time
where we were talking about how do you
detect dose during cancer treatment and
I was outlining one proposed way that
we're thinking of using this F
center-based dosimeter which changes
color when it gets a raid
you can implant it in the tumor and as
it moves from things like breathing or
swallowing you could feed back to the
proton beam and only irradiated when
it's in range or play nuclear operation
and try not to hit the sides however
whatever you want to do and there's
multiple implantation options for this
we've thought about things like
implanting a fiber-optic cable into the
tumor and then having a port on the side
of you that could do some in body
spectrometry which would be pretty cool
you could also put it all on a chip you
could have the emitter either a
broadband or single color LED the F
Center and the spectrometer all in a
chip that's implanted and with RF with
radiofrequency power transfer so you
don't need to put a fiber-optic port and
plug it into the side of you or however
it goes and what we're doing next in
this development is nailing down what
color change is given by what dose so
the physics develop an on-chip version
find a biocompatible Cape casing we've
done the IP part which is pretty cool as
you can see with patent office at least
has taken in the application but it's
neat that you need to know pretty much
everything you learn at MIT to pull off
a project like this from the nuclear
physics stuff to the material science to
the 22:07 one electronics to the medical
stuff for biology to the financial stuff
for econ in order to pull off an actual
nuclear startup project like this you
need everything you learn here which is
kind of a neat case study but now let's
get back into what does a Seibert really
mean in terms of increased risk usually
means the increased risk of some sort of
long-term biological effect whether it's
cancer or some other genetic effects
let's say mutations anything that would
take a while to manifest and would
manifest by slow but steady cell
division and if you notice the
difference between adults and whole
population let's see yeah so sorry you
can see right here that these are not
very much dosed let's say in realm of
ten to the minus two sieverts can give
you some increased risk for cancer or
some other effects so we're talking like
on the realm of 40 millisieverts or so
would give you some additional cancer
risk that's not a lot of dose that's up
to about the limit of the occupational
dose that you're allowed so when we talk
about how much is too much I've taken
some excerpts from this committee on
radiation protection document this is
from Turner but the entire document as I
mentioned is up on the learning module
site so you guys can see the actual
verbiage where this is defined so your
lifetime dose should never exceed in
tens of millions
means in some years if you get a little
bit less dose you can get a little bit
more dose and still be considered safe
or not have any appreciable increased
risk and while you're working you should
never get more than about 50
millisieverts in a given year how is it
for radiation workers so for you guys
what dose are you allowed per year
working at the reactor five REM per year
which is 50 millisieverts okay awesome
so it's
oh sure yeah to jump back to that if
you're saying that there's actually
tabulated differences for different
organs that's where they come from
because you can take let's say you can
take less radiation to the same organ
and get the same dose in sieverts
measured an equivalent risk so I
wouldn't be surprised if these are the
organs that you're not allowed to are
radiate as much I'm surprised the eye
isn't here as I say retina anywhere no
okay well that's just one table it's not
necessarily the complete answer yeah so
50 millisieverts isn't that much
although if you think of it in the old
xkcd units a banana equivalent dose
eating a banana gives you about point
one microsieverts so you would have to
get eat fifty thousand bananas in a year
no I'm sorry five hundred thousand
bananas in order to incur that and well
yeah I was talking to someone at dinner
last night about the banana burning
experiment where we measured the
activity in becquerels and then we can
calculate how much dose and Siebert's it
would take and he said how many bananas
would it take to get some increased
cancer risk about double this it would
take about a million bananas to give you
about a hundred millisieverts and i said
you know what else it would cause and he
goes 100 millisieverts no [ __ ] and i
said that's right yeah yeah he totally
didn't plan that but it just worked out
that way yeah and then how much is too
much let's say for the general public
for background for excluding things like
natural background and medical exposures
you're not supposed to get about more
than 1 millisievert just walking about
outside and you don't tend to get that
much more now why does anyone think why
our medical exposures not included
despite them being pretty radioactive
procedures yeah
they are targeted and so they could give
a lot of dose to certain organs but the
amount of dose isn't necessarily why we
don't count medical procedures anyone
have any idea yeah
in some cases you'll get like if you go
to the dentist you'll get a lend x-ray
but let's say you get a huge chest x-ray
right why don't we care that a chest
x-ray is way more than you get because
these things tend to save lives so
you're absolutely willing to get extra
radiation exposure that may have a
delayed effect if the immediate effect
is to save your life so you know
question or no okay
yeah so we don't count medical of things
because chances are you're doing them to
improve or save your life so what's a
little bit of radiation compared to
let's say finding the blood clot or the
aneurysm or whatever it would take and
then how much is enough this is the
table that you're familiar with yeah
they actually talk about the lens of the
eye and that's you know a heftier dose
but also the lens of the eye is not a
very massive organ so this would mean do
not stick a remaining eye in Neutron
beam right yeah or you've seen that
sticker do not stare into laser with
remaining.i yeah the same goes for the
neutron beam ports coming out of the
reactor
yeah but the lens of the eye can take a
fair bit more dose per unit mass then
the whole body the lens of the eye is
not a particularly fast developing
tissue it can cloud up with an insane
amount of radiation exposure that would
take a lot more than a hundred 50
millisieverts to do though and then
things like 500 millisieverts for skin
hands feet pretty much just groups of
muscle bone and dead skin that aren't
really not much is going on biologically
you know Bloods flowing through it but
that's about it and notice that the
regulations do differ a little bit but
on the whole they're fairly similar same
for the eye same for the feet same for
the year cumulative is a little
different this says 10 millisieverts
times age this allows you a little bit
more whichever recommendations you
follow they're all pretty similar and
our knowledge of how much dose leads to
how much risk hasn't changed a ton in
the last like decade or so there's been
all sorts of arguments for or against it
as anyone heard of this LNT or linear
no-threshold model
of DOS versus risk this is something
we'll talk a lot about on the last day
of class this is the theory that the
amount of risk versus the amount of dose
is linear and no threshold means that
every little bit of dose gives you
additional risk this is not supported
very much by science actually I'd say
it's not supported by science the
converse argument is also not supported
by science we just don't have the
statistics at super low doses to say
what happens but the official
recommendation is that there is a unit
of dose that we define as nothing and
it's point O 1 millisieverts about a
hundred bananas per event let's say oh
yeah where does it say yeah per source
or practice so eating 100 bananas in one
sitting is considered to give you zero
additional risk according to the
official guidelines so the guidelines
put in place do not follow the linear
no-threshold model but any one sets
would claim that one or the autumn other
model is absolutely correct as either
got a huge sample size of people that we
don't know about or is probably
extrapolating beyond what the data will
tell them so you'll see this argument
flaring up quite a bit for the last day
of class we'll have you read some
arguments for and against the linear
no-threshold model that aren't just
blogs on the internet but they're
actually published articles that a past
peer review and it's really hard to tell
exactly what's going on at low doses but
meanwhile let's focus on what you do get
that we can measure the actual
contribution from background levels is
about 50% radon this is a natural decay
product of radium it's just everywhere
it's here right now it's through through
all through the atmosphere this is why
you want your basement to be rather well
ventilated because it's a heavy noble
gas that accumulates down in
unventilated basements so you don't
actually want your house to be sealed up
super tight because you can have radon
accumulation especially if you happen to
live near a granite deposit or on
granite bedrock which like everyone in
New Hampshire does radon levels are a
little higher there's actually a story
about a guy that used to work at a
nuclear plant somewhere in Pennsylvania
I don't know where but he lived on top
of a pretty good granite deposit
was a few parts-per-million radium or so
the radon levels in his house or in his
basement were much much higher than
would normally be allowed for background
and this guy used to set off the
radiation alarms coming into work then
he would breathe the nice clean
radiation free air in the plant and go
out without setting off the alarm
eventually something had to be done I
don't actually know what was done but
then you can find that original story
that would be pretty cool
cosmic rays another source that you
can't shield from is about another 10%
and we'll talk a lot about where these
things come from terrestrial radiation
well we'll count that as stuff in the
soil stuff in the cinder block wood
happens to be a fairly radioactive
substance pound-for-pound but it's not
very dense compared to things like brick
or banana ashes it's probably about the
same as wood internal coming from you
you'll have this on problem set number
eight because you all now know your
internal radioactivity thanks to going
to environmental health and safety did
anyone see anything disconcerting in
your spectra other than a tiny little
potassium peak anyone I'd say I'd say oh
it's too bad but that's great you know
especially for you guys that work at the
reactor medical x-rays it's assumed that
everyone gets a couple of these a year
you all go to the dentist and look for
cavities you break something you get me
to get a hand x-ray of your hand or foot
and this is let's say an average amount
of medical x-rays and a little bit of
stuff left over consumer products this
isn't counting things like Fiestaware
those orange glazed plates and bowls
that were painted with a rhenium based
like neon orange paint so we also don't
tend to drink from raviga raters anymore
has anyone ever seen or heard of a
raviga rater
or even earlier yeah so like back in the
20s people would put radium or in these
containers and pour water in it and say
natural radioactivity gets in at corkers
like you know croup or the Jimmy legs
our roommate or you know a stigma toyed
rheumatism or whatever other quack
diseases there were in the 20s you can
still find him on eBay and that's not
accounted for in today's consumer
products but this all accumulates the
amount of dose that you tend to get on
your own you might get it couple
millisieverts a year of dose just from
background especially depending on where
you are and the big one whose spectrum I
think you're all familiar with by now is
that of radon because we saw most of
these peaks in the bananas anyone have
any idea why you would find so many
radon decay products in bananas given
that radon everywhere we did notice
elevated levels of specifically bismuth
2 14 and actinium I think 228 was the
isotope we saw where would those come
from
so what absolutely yeah whatever radium
is coming out from the bedrock that
radon has to come up through the soil
that happens to decay in the soil
it makes LED this myth polonium other
heavy metals that are up taken by the
plants tissues in addition radon
daughter products can played out on the
leaves themselves so this is one of
those reasons that smoking is such a bad
thing to do aside from the chemical
effects you have giant fields of high
surface area tobacco that you then
concentrate and dry up into these tiny
little sticks you have an enormous
amount of leaf surface area and dry
vegetation that is up taken all these
radon daughter products so most the dose
you get from smoking is led bismuth
polonium actinium radio alpha emitters
as we saw last time to remind you guys
of the quality factor for alpha
particles it's as big as it gets
anyone remember why that is
why are alphas so damaging if they get
into your tissues they are big so they
have high mass and short range coming
from their high charge high relative
charge they have quite high stopping
power and they will deposit a lot of
energy very close to where they are
emitted so their range is very small so
that they are that armor-piercing bullet
analogy kind of comes to just an
armor-piercing bullet that explodes
right out of the barrel of the gun and
they do quite a bit of radiation damage
and you jump back to the right slide
without inducing a seizure
I think we've looked before at the radon
decay chain this is a simplified version
because there are different branches or
different possibilities for decay but
some of them have extremely low
percentages so this one simplified quite
a bit but it is whenever radon decays it
emits it gives off a bunch of alpha and
beta emitters that last anywhere from
minutes or seconds to days and so so
they'll give off for every radon atom
that you absorb you end up getting four
or five alphas and betas depending on
how long it stays into your system and
then mapping out radon in the u.s. you
have quite different amount of radon
dose depending on where you are and I
wanted to skip ahead and overlay a
couple of maps of the US so this is a
terrestrial oh I'm sorry that's the
wrong one let's just look at this one
yeah anyone notice any patterns here
where do you tend to get the most radon
what sort of features would one live
near when you get a lot of radon dose
Mountains which tend to be made of rocks
which tend to contain a lot of radium
especially granite and other such rocks
the Conway granite named after up in
Conway New Hampshire is about 52 parts
per million uranium or radium so it's a
fairly toasty rock you can actually tell
that you know you can tell there with
your Geiger counter if it's count long
enough that there is a little bit of
radioactive ore in that Conway granite
not nearly enough to matter at all and
certainly not enough to stop you from
making fancy kitchen countertops but I
wonder if folks would buy those if they
knew that there was 52 parts per million
of something with a half-life of 9
billion years I somehow think it would
matter to people but it really doesn't
yes engrave that right if they've made
the radiation symbol a little induction
stove that would be pretty slick yeah
and then in terms of relative radon risk
how much actually matters I like this
graph despite being difficult to read it
actually shows how much the average
indoor level compares to all the
different things you could do like
getting 2,000 chest x-rays per year
versus a hundred times the average
indoor level that's about what I heard
that fellow in Pennsylvania had is like
a hundred or eighty times the normal
radon levels from living underground on
this giant granite deposit it's like
getting 2,000 chest x-rays per year or
something like smoking four packs a day
I know some people that do this they
don't tend to be that afraid of the
radiation that they're picking in from
they're taking in from smoking but yeah
it's a it's pretty insane how much
radiation you get and even think of
getting people are afraid to get one
chest x-ray which is not even on this
map right one chest x-ray worth of
radiation gives you much much less than
living for a year in a house which we
all tend to do then if you live in a
brick or cinderblock house you actually
get a fair bit more radiation because
these are fairly radioactive building
materials and I'll show you those
activity levels in just a sec as far as
exposure sources again to look at the
relative amount of terrestrial gamma-ray
exposure you can correlate that pretty
well with not green regions on a
topological map so look at the really
low levels down here correlates with
low-lying vegetative areas around here
colors are a little more extreme on my
screen but you can see this is this is
all low lying right here from Louisiana
Florida up the east coast until you get
to the Appalachian Mountains and such so
pretty striking correlations there and
it all comes from what we call the
primordial nuclides these are unstable
nuclides that are have such long
half-lives that they still exist despite
the universe being 15 billion years old
or whatever supernova formed our solar
system being five plus billion years old
things that we've already studied almost
death like potassium-40 and you can see
that's about 0.01 1% of all potassium is
radioactive potassium-40 about 10% of
which gives off gammas and what is it
ninety ten I forget the split but can
give off either betas and then a gamma
or positrons in then a gamma then things
like rubidium in the same column as
sodium potassium and cesium so it
behaves kind of like a salt like element
there should be some fur there any for
chlorine to some of the other important
ones to know a platinum so anyone has
any platinum jewellery does anyone have
any platinum jewellery good answer yeah
I don't either I teach at a college so
also I don't like wearing jewelry yeah
but there'll be all sorts of these
primordial nuclides that you can't
really do anything about they're just
there
note that the half-lives are really
really long and as you know now the
half-life is going to be inversely
proportional to the activity despite
almost all indium I mean look at that
95% of the indium that you'll find emits
betas doesn't stop people from using it
as these awesome glass to metal seals
for vacuum components because once in a
while it might emit a beta ray like a
hold gasket might emit a beta once every
millennium or so but these half-lives
actually are measurable and that kind of
begs the question are there elements
with longer half-lives that are just too
long to measure you think of like what's
a what does it mean to have a half-life
of 10 to the 15 years given that the
universe is on the order of 10 to the 10
years old right is it possible that all
nuclei will decay to the end of time
I've seen some documentary such things
and don't call this a science that say
oh 10 to the 40 years from now the last
protons decay or the last whatever I el
Amin's decay into all protons and
neutrons er don't know if that's true
but it does make me wonder are some of
the other so-called stable elements just
have ridiculously long half-lives
something to think about
let's take a look at the building
materials and see what's in well the
typical things around us right now you
can see how much granite radioactive
thorium and potassium are in these
building materials and how many usually
is measured in Pico Curie's per gram a
Pico Curie is already less than a Becker
l program because it curious what three
point seven of three times ten to the
three point seven times ten to the ten
Becker ELLs and a Pico is a ten to the
minus twelve so things on the order of a
few Pico Curie's per gram a gram of that
material might emit one disintegration
per second not a lot of radiation but
take a look at how much potassium there
is in Granite you know nano Curie's per
gram that's getting into the you know
integers worth of Becker else if you
look at would check that Oh anyone heard
of potash before it's one of ways we get
potassium so if you take wood based
things and you burn them in a fire you
drive off all the carbon in the water
you're left with these kind of white and
like salt and pepper ashes
that's potash that's the ashes left over
in the pot after you burn stuff in a
fire they're quite potassium rich so I
think what we'll do next year instead of
burning a bunch of food is just burn a
bunch of wood love like a nice bonfire
collect the ashes and we can see how
much potassium there isn't wood which
pound-for-pound if you see on this list
is the most radioactive building
material there is just that what happens
to be pretty inexpensive and consists
mostly of water lignin and other
Carboniferous materials they don't have
carbon-14 on this list but let's take a
look at some of the other ones so
sandstone cement has a pretty toasty
signature to it gypsum drywall 180s what
is it 13 parts per million uranium and
all the drywall you tend to find anyone
scared yet because you shouldn't be it's
like I mentioned before this is the this
is the slide I want to show it at most
folks in the general public there is
such a dose as nothing and that's pretty
much what you get from let's say a day
is worth of being around these building
materials is just about nothing
back to the building materials there we
go
seawater is another great source of
radioactivity enough so that people have
actually was at proposed harvesting
uranium from seawater so the total
amount of activity in the ocean there's
something like 11 EXA becquerels of
radiation contained in the uranium in
the seawater which means you should just
be able to have a gigantic trawler
flying out around in the ocean and just
floating through the seawater picking up
atoms of uranium here and there cuz
technically there's enough to power the
world for like two thousand years the
problem is the ocean is big it doesn't
stop people from actually working on it
so it's neat to think that there's a
whole lot of carbon-14 and tritium and
uranium in seawater 300 Piko Curie's per
liter anyone have any idea why there's
so much more potassium activity than
anything else in seawater it's cuz it's
salty yeah and potassium is just like
sodium so there'll be a fair bit of
potassium in the sea water 0.0 0.0 1 1 7
percent of which is potassium 40 and so
last year people asks what uranium from
seawater how is that even possible so I
want to this this is the part in the
course where I'm going to pull out a lot
more recent papers to show you some of
the cooler innovations going on so you
could use this adsorbent and adsorbate
seni one know what adsorption means not
absorption adsorption is when something
sticks to the surface of something
absorption with a B is when it actually
gets incorporated into the bulk so folks
are thinking about making high surface
area materials that can adsorb
selectively atoms of uranium so you send
out this huge braided net or a huge
stack of absorb adsorbing material with
a D and just go around in the ocean you
know attach them to tankers or cargo
ships and just have them pull in product
as they go from coast to coast and by
actually changing around the chemistry
and the geometry
this you can enhance things specifically
for uranium by about a factor of three
and this yellow cake right here next to
an actual ruler that's 50 millimeters
right there that was obtained directly
from seawater so you can actually pull
yellow cake out of the ocean it's not
very much of it and the way these work
is there are interesting compounds that
selectively absorb uranium into their
structure not by direct chemical bonding
but by well getting something like
something close like for example my wife
tends to study metals bonding to
proteins and it's not necessarily always
a full chemical bond like you might
think but the protein can kind of wrap
around a metal ion transport it places
similar thing going here I'm not going
to pontificate anymore on it because the
title has the word organic in it and I
am definitely not an organic chemist
don't want to tell you anything wrong
but I do want to tell you you can
actually see this paper to find out what
sort of compounds selectively grab onto
uranium and if there's a seawater
floating through and uranium happens to
flow nearby it can bond to it you can
then somehow squeeze out or burn off
that ads orbit and there you get uranium
now let's talk about what's in the body
and interpreting the spectra that you
got from EHS your full body spectra if
you take a look at how much uranium
there is at the body
oh there's some every one of you has got
about a Becker role of radiation of
uranium in the body but if you look at
the relative amounts raid it was it the
only things that really matter a ton
potassium-40 about 4.4 kilobit girls per
human so each of you is giving off 4400
potassium gammas per second most of them
just flow right through all the other
people and then carbon-14 about 3.7
Killa becquerels pretty interesting to
know just how much radioactive stuff you
have in your own body you will need this
table for homework number eight when I
ask you a pretty fun question then
there's all the various medical
procedures the ones that aren't counted
in your annual dose because they tend to
save people but now let's look at the
dose at millirem so if you want to
figure out what this is in seever
it's just divide by a hundred so a
regular old chest x-ray 0.1 let's see
how does it go one hundred and hundred
rim in a sievert yeah so about 0.1
millisieverts or a thousand banana
equivalent dose not terrible so why if
we go back to that chart of all those
relative risks if you look at the
average indoor level it's like getting
well I would have to guess maybe forty
chest x-rays per year based on this
rather crude scale and you're allowed to
get around a millisievert or a few
millisieverts of radiation per year that
sounds like it checks out mathematically
let's look at some of the other crazier
ones dental bitewing yeah so anyone ever
bite down on something where you have to
get an x-ray through the side of your
mouth quite negligible amount of dose
yet they still put the lead apron on you
I'm guessing that's mostly for show
because that's very very little dosed
it's well beyond the 0.1 microsieverts
of allow of something that accounts as
nothing but there's not a lot of dose
going into these things let's see what
really does give you a whole lot of dose
10 millisieverts for a CT scan or a
whole body CT screening that's a pretty
hefty amount of dose that's right there
with one procedure you may get more than
your normal annual background dose but
if you're going in to look for stuff
chances are you need to find whatever
you're looking for so we don't count it
and it may give you a slightly higher
chance of developing cancer much later
down the line when that cell that gets
mutated divides but it's probably gonna
save your life in the next hour or the
next day
so definitely worth it let's see the
worst what's the worst procedure we can
find
noncardiac embolisation i don't know
enough biology words to know exactly
what that means yeah I think we all know
what noncardiac means good
this isn't 701 to non-medical procedures
or more medical procedures I'm sorry
where's the technetium scan yeah
notice how many of these things have
technetium imaging where you'll inject
technetium into a certain organ or a
certain vascular or limp or whatever
system some of these things can give you
a fair bit of dose like again maybe a
heart stress rest tests can give you
double or triple your normal background
dose this is why you have to declare two
airports if you've just had a medical
imaging procedure because this is well
more than enough to pick up on any sort
of airport radiation monitor so again if
you ever get a medical procedure with
any sort of radiation anything do
declare it because it's quite measurable
yeah
then there's radiation from altitude I
may have mentioned already that the
reason that pilots can't fly for a
certain number of hours is not fatigue
but it's radiation exposure when you
start to look at how many micro C would
you get per hour on the ground 0.03
right about down at that hanging around
for an hour is a negligible dose you go
up to international air travel that goes
up by a factor of a little more than a
hundred and so you get a fair bit of
radiation exposure if you take your
annual allowable limit of occupational
limit of 50 millisieverts divided by
three point seven micro sieverts
you're getting close to 86 what is it
how many hours in a year see there's
three times 10 to the 7 seconds in a
year so divide that by 3600 that's
getting on the realm of 10,000 that's
about the conversion factor so you can't
spend your life in the air because you'd
get too much radiation according to the
occupational risks and so actually in
addition to some interesting
measurements that have been published in
papers we've actually had students go
out and build radiation altima ters
based on the EMA an MIT Geiger counter
removing the speaker of course because
you don't want to clicking Geiger
counter on a plane you know that's be
kind of a stressful situation let me
show you one example of these these are
also published from a paper but we have
pretty similar data from if you want go
talk to max Carlson one of my graduate
students who hooked up his Geiger
counter to an alarm clock the case that
had a Arduino in it I think this was a
poor choice of case for a plane because
it looks kind of like a time bomb but
luckily nobody found it and he was able
to get the data yeah
but you can see just how much more data
you get and you can correlate the height
that you're at with the dose in this
case micro roentgens per hour micro rad
depending on in what is it ambiguous
unit definition right there but it's
quite noticeable so for those of you who
have built Geiger counters and have cell
phones and don't want to have a fake
time bomb you can actually hook in your
Geiger counter to the microphone port of
your cell phone and with a few available
radiation apps you could actually
monitor your dose in micro sieverts
assuming that it all comes from gamma
rays which is most of what a lot of
cosmic rays will produce so it's a
pretty safe approximation that your dose
and gray flying on the plane is also
your dose and sieverts because it's
whole body and it's gammas so I'd say
try this at home kids this is what are
those things I recommend you try out
speaking of these cosmic rays where did
they come from well this is a question
that's been under debate and was more
completely answered just a few years ago
they come from very high-energy
particles from somewhere it had been
argued do they come mostly from solar
flares or they come from elsewhere in
the galaxy mostly we're talking about
things like high-energy protons or other
charged particles we're also talking
neutrinos anyone know about how many
neutrinos are
are theorized to pass through you every
second
trillions yeah something like that but
they basically don't interact with
matter as I showed you guys near the
beginning it takes a gigantic salt mine
full of water and exploding
photomultiplier tubes in order to catch
two or three neutrinos a day if you're
luck
so let's say those don't really matter
in terms of background dose but when
those high-energy particles interact
with the oxygen and nitrogen up here in
the atmosphere they produce a shower and
cascade of additional ionizations and
heavy high-energy particles so it's been
said that solar flares and such will
accelerate charged particles from the
plasma and the Sun towards earth they're
deflected somewhat by the magnetic field
of the earth but they tend to enter
right here at the what is it at these uh
other poles I'm sorry that's the simple
word I was looking for until recently in
2001 they were looking specifically at
the evidence for or against the idea
that coronal mass ejections which means
large ejections of mass from the outer
layers the sparser layers of the Sun was
responsible for most charged particles
and cosmic rays skipping the stuff
that's not in bold it appears to be that
this eme both shocked scenario has been
overvalued so for a while folks were
saying most cosmic rays come from the
Sun that's our nearest star by making
really really careful measurements of
the energy and lifetime of these cosmic
rays this has actually been somewhat
disproven that this is the major source
of cosmic rays which is pretty cool but
let's talk about where they actually
come from reactions that you can
probably understand
so if stream lehigh protons enter the
atmosphere they all start as high-energy
protons and when protons are high enough
energy and like I do probably in every
class ever I'm gonna pull up Janice to
show you something they can undergo
what's called spallation it's the same
principle that the spallation neutron
source at Oak Ridge National Lab works
on is shoot in extremely high-energy
protons out come neutrons so as usual it
didn't clone the screen right so just
bear with me for a sec
I'd like to for probably the first time
in this course switched databases to the
incident proton data is that actually
working okay good so we'll leave the
incident Neutron data we'll go to the
incident proton data I think we'll stick
with the same library let's see how much
they have not much but enough to matter
because there's a lot of nitrogen-14 up
in the air let's see what happens when
protons hit nitrogen-14
all the way at high energy so don't
quite know what a negative cross-section
refers to but at high energies this is
definitely a possible event and let's
see there's not a lot of cross sections
to look at here let's try oxygen-16
not much okay well stick to the slides
then so when a high-energy protons
strikes a nucleus it can eject neutrons
and those neutrons can then cause
activation reactions and then emit
things like proton or tritium leading to
that's where your carbon-14 comes from
comes from nitrogen 14 so in comes a
high-energy proton releases a neutron
that Neutron hits nitrogen 14 releases a
proton out comes carbon 14 so this is
why it's being constantly generated in
the atmosphere it's not like there's a
certain amount that's was there at the
beginning of the universe and decays
because it's half-life is only 5,700
years so this is part of why radiocarbon
dating works because we have cosmic rays
it's kind of a neat connection to make
there weren't cosmic rays all the
carbon-14 would decay pretty quickly in
you know the universe timescale and we
wouldn't have this form of radiocarbon
dating and then same thing for tritium
production in the atmosphere this is
where some of that tritium naturally
comes from is it makes carbon-12 which
is the normal form of carbon but out
comes tritium which there is going to be
some constant isotopic fraction of
tritium in all the worlds hydrogen some
of its being generated in real time and
we do have these spallation sources on
earth like I mentioned the spallation
neutron source
a gigantic synchrotron we've seen these
before which just injects in this case
protons which circle around and around
and around accelerating until some of
them are extracted and fire onto things
like a liquid mercury target some
neutron rich liquid metal so you want
something that's very Neutron rich you
want something that's very dense you
want something that's fluid so you can
cool it better and you want something
with high thermal conductivity that's
where the metal comes in so a liquid
metal you can keep cool really well
because when you're firing lots of 800
muv protons into it you generate a
tremendous amount of heat and this is
what the actual thing looks like you can
get tours of this down in Tennessee at
the Oak Ridge National Lab actually I've
driven up here before I recognize this
from a map that's pretty cool so where
the actual Neutron Sciences stuff
happens in the world the scientists it
with their targets there's quite a bit
of stuff going on behind it so there is
a gigantic you can see right that's a
parking lot for scale there's a gigantic
linear accelerator shooting into the
synchrotron ring which then fires the
protons here into the target into one of
any number of end stations which creates
an you know not quite push button but
turn honorable pulsed neutron source
which is pretty slick and again parking
lot for scale takes a lot of magnets to
bend an 800 MeV proton that's what it
actually looks like has anyone ever seen
one of these cyclotron these
synchrotrons like at Brookhaven or an
Oak Ridge or it anywhere they're quite
interesting things the closest one to us
is the NS LS or the National synchrotron
light source version two at Brookhaven
National Lab it's like a two and a half
hour drive down in Long Island I don't
know if they're doing tours yet but it's
about a kilometer around and I was told
they did bike races around it to see who
could beat the protons which of course
everybody loses but they are pretty
insane collections of magnets vacuum
equipment and once in a while a proton
will pass through and then there's the
spallation source itself so this is what
the target looks like it's gonna have to
be liquid metal cooled in and then out
of here come lots and lots and lots of
neutrons
enough neutrons that you still need hot
cells to deal with things they're still
quite radioactive and activated but it's
not a reactor otherwise of making
neutrons
speaking of has anybody seen the pulsed
fusion source that we have down in
Northwest 13 no we have a pulsed neutron
source then you can come take a look at
it say it's an electrostatic fusion
pulsed machine there's a whole bunch of
tritium and deuterium in this palladium
sponge what happens to hold hydrogen and
it's isotopes very well and with a very
quick pulse you can have a tiny pulse of
fusion and generate about 10 to the 8th
neutrons that it actually is a
push-button neutron source so if you
want to see a neutron source beyond
reactors go down to the vault in
Northwest 13 and ask to see that we did
it a quick experiment before trying to
activate cellphones to see what was in
them we did not generate enough neutrons
to do so but this cell phone is
definitely seen a few fusion Neutron
pulses and we checked later it's not
giving off any residual radioactivity at
least we can measure that was a fun
failed experiment and then comes the
craziness since it's about five of five
of I want to get into things that will
definitely not be on the exam so just
sit back and enjoy and stop taking notes
complete insanity can happen with super
high energy electrons we've already
talked about bremsstrahlung we haven't
talked about we have talked about
synchrotron radiation where you have a
charged particle going along a magnetic
field line it changes direction and
gives off x-rays we haven't talked about
inverse Compton scattering interesting
process here in comes a low-energy
photon hits an electron out comes a
higher energy photon Compton scattering
usually think of as the other way around
where a high-energy photon comes in
scatters off an electron loses energy in
this case a high-energy electron
colliding with a low-energy photon can
impart energy to the photon and you can
actually calculate or in this case I've
just taken from a paper the energy
gained from inverse Compton scattering
as well as whatever cross-section there
is
and even though this is a very
infrequent process while the universe is
pretty big and contains a lot of things
that have magnetic fields like stars and
black whatever else had happens have
magnetic fields and you can identify
radio sources by looking for these
inverse Compton scattered x-rays so the
Chandra x-ray map I believe a piece of
which or a receiver for which is up in
the building in Porter Square do you
guys go down three stops on the red line
you'll see this like little area full of
Japanese noodle shops Lesley University
a bunch of galleries and in a little and
in a little bit I think it's still there
in a little sign it says oh and there's
the Chandra x-ray Observatory you know
whatever they may or may not have moved
but I recommend you check it out and
then what happens to those electrons
well they can actually decay pretty
interesting things and so some of this
inverse Compton scattering has gone into
the evidence for against where cosmic
rays come from because you should see
electrons of a certain energy after
undergoing this process I think I will
skip ahead oh I won't skip ahead and so
what these charged particle what these
cosmic rays can produce is what's called
positive negative or neutral pion other
subatomic particles with mass is
somewhere between protons and electrons
that themselves can undergo different
reactions are different decays into
muons and don't worry muons and pi ons
and such are not part of the topic of
this course but they do have known
lifetimes they do have known masses and
charges they do have known stopping
powers we should be able to measure them
and there is a cosmic muon detector at
Boston University rather it's a pair of
detectors that looks for this
coincidence of one muon scattering off
one detector or interacting and another
particle being sensed directly beneath
so we can actually sense these muons to
confirm or refute the theories about
where they come from
in terms of cosmic rays and these
neutral pion x' are end up what end up
creating these gamma rays I think they
were around like the 70 something MeV
range so if these theories about them
are correct we should be able to sense
these
gamma rays and since how many of them
they are as a function of energy that's
not what I wanted to do
let me recreate presentation mode
because this is definitely delving into
the kind of stuff that well I'm not an
expert in so a quick detour into some
atomic physics you guys probably have
heard of that protons and neutrons are
not the smallest building blocks of
matter they themselves can be composed
of quarks and antiquarks with different
charges and different masses they're
given different flavors I don't know who
came up with this terminology but it's
kind of fun things get kind of whimsical
when you get into subatomic physics and
these Proteas quarks and the gluons
between them are what composes protons
neutrons and their antimatter
counterparts and these sorts of things
can also undergo their own decay in
reactions so when beta decay occurs it's
actually one of these up quarks turning
into a down quark and releasing an
electron and an anti-neutrino but again
we're not gonna delve even deeper into
this there are other particles composed
of other arrangements of quarks so if
you have just and up and down you have a
positive pi on which should have a
charge I think once two thirds and ones
minus one-third yep that is correct so a
new a plus pi on should have a charge of
one thirds the charge of an electron so
you should you know the mass of some
particle because you know the number of
quarks and you know the charge of it you
should be able to calculate its own
stopping power and figure out how many
should get through the atmosphere and
such or how many get absorbed in your
detector and so when a very high-energy
proton collides with an atmospheric
molecule creates neutrons creates a
shower of pi ons these neutral pion x'
much like electron positron interaction
can produce their own gammas so they can
spontaneously decay from particles that
are mass into gamma rays of pure energy
which then go on to create their own
shower of electrons and positrons by
pair production
because as we saw the higher energy you
go for photons the more likely pair
production becomes and there you have it
this is part of the 2201 stuff but taken
to the enth degree and then the evidence
for pi on decay comes from extremely
fine measurements of the number of these
PI ons as a function of energy or in
this case look at that there was it was
per centimeter squared per second what
does that unit physically mean I'm not
gonna get into that but at any rate
there are different models for how many
of these peons and their or their
high-energy gamma decay products should
be observed and by looking at those very
carefully you can tell where they came
from should they have come from coronal
mass discharges so we should know what
energy those protons should be or some
other source okay I'm gonna stop there
because it is five of so after that
crazy detour give you guys 10 minutes to
D gas and absorb some neutral pion gamma
decay products will meet upstairs in 10
minutes for an exam review
you